Now, let's think. What happens when this object hits the ground?
Well, now it's no longer accelerating, so Galileo's statement doesn't make any sense.
In fact, Galileo didn't spend too much time thinking about objects at rest.
He was much more interested in motion. So, let's think.
What would Newton be saying now?
Now that the balls are at rest, the acceleration is 0.
According to this equation, which is a law of physics, it must always be true.
A 0 acceleration must correspond to a force of 0.
So, what happened? Did gravity just turn off all of a sudden?
No, of course not.
The ball is still being pulled down by gravity,
and I'm going to label gravity as mg from now on
where m is the mass of this ball and g is the acceleration due to gravity, that 10 m/s².
What's going on?
According to this force diagram, the ball ought to be accelerating downwards.
There's a force downwards.
Well, here we're saved by the fact that force is what's called a vector.
I'm representing this force with an arrow, because this force
has a direction associated with it--downwards.
By adding a force in the opposite direction, we can actually cancel this force.
Which of the following arrows do you think best represents the force needed
to cancel this downwards mg.
Choose what you think is the best answer.